if you probably picked any other career
and you had spent a decade working on it
and were really good at it you'd
probably be really successful and have a
good life
how much money has the first feature
that you made living life made
total
it probably hasn't made really barely
any money i mean it was
uh
they paid a small fee to me
to go kind of work on it when they first
picked it up and they paid to finish it
and put it on film and release it and
market it
but i don't think they ever even made
their money back on it i mean
it had a small theatrical release in a
couple cities
it played you know
on um
i think internationally in a few
countries in a few tv markets
but the distributor was
you know they were kind of this tiny
little indie distributor you know at the
time back then there was all these
little companies popping up
and i think they meant well but i don't
think they really knew how to kind of
get a film out there and so i don't
think it ended up really making very
much money for them i definitely didn't
recoup the money that my parents had
given me to
to make the movie but again for me it
was never about that i mean it was they
were never expecting that in the first
place i mean it wasn't like an
investment either they you know it was
the money i would have used they would
have given me if i had you know gone to
pay to a film school or something right
and so
um
uh yeah i don't think it made money but
it obviously made just so much for me in
terms of it's what gave me the
inspiration to start this film festival
for young filmmakers which then led to
starting to do commercials which then
led me back to making a film again and
so
it was definitely a life-changing
experience um and yeah
just an incredible thing that i was able
to pull off at such a young age
do you think a filmmaker should expect
to make money or recoup their costs for
their first feature film
um it's hard to say you know i mean i
think that it all probably depends on
the scale and size of the film i mean i
think that
ideally
you start something small and you build
from there
and
obviously things are changing all the
time you know i think budgets are
getting smaller because they're being
forced to be because the people are
paying less for them your distributors
are
um
but
i think
especially if you're going to make a
move for any sort of larger amount of
money that isn't your own money you
should try to have the attention be to
make money because you don't want to
just be taking people's money and with
no intention to make it back obviously
but
i think the best thing would be to kind
of start something small that you know
you could pull off and make good but
then would have the ability to maybe
make some money back you know i mean
maybe you could find a contained film
that would only cost
a hundred grand or 200 grand or
something which is still a lot of money
but it's probably a more realistic
amount of money that you could make back
versus a couple million dollars even if
you could get that money you know
and so
um
but i think to make money personally as
a filmmaker that's a always a long shot
you know i think that's multiple films
and being very successful when you would
ever do that i mean i think right at
this stage for most filmmakers it's just
you're just lucky to have been able to
make the film you know and if anything
happens beyond that that's just you know
a wonderful dream
and have it shown in theaters as well i
mean that's that's a rarity too yeah for
sure i mean especially now more than
ever it's it's rare um to get something
in the theater uh
and
if you'd asked me several years ago i
probably would have been like that's the
ultimate thing now
it's hard to even say right because
you probably have a lot better reach if
you were on something like netflix you
know it's not as theatrical and there's
a lot of issues probably with with
some of that distribution because it's
like it's on there and it gets lost
right it's not very curated but
it's it's hard to say i think there's
gonna be a lot of change in the next few
years in terms of how people see films
and and what is the best way to get it
out to people but of course i like
nothing more than being in a theater
with a bunch of people and watching it
and kind of feeling with them so i would
love to always be able to have a film in
a theater for sure
so the filmmaker quandaria if you want
to make films
you may or may not make a living at it
you may or may not have to
take other jobs
what are your thoughts on that what's
your advice to other filmmakers
it's definitely the hardest thing about
being a filmmaker right i mean
if you probably picked any other career
and you had spent a decade working on it
and were really good at it you'd
probably be really successful and have a
good life you know whether you're as a
doctor or business or whatever right
whereas the filmmaker you could do that
and you could still be pretty poor after
being pretty successful right or
struggling to get by
and so i think it's probably one of the
hardest careers you could ever pick
because even when you get successful
it's it's still you got to keep going
right
so
it's definitely not
for people that want the easiest life of
course but
i think if you are that kind of person
and i'm one of those people there's
nothing else i would do i wouldn't know
what i would do if i couldn't make
movies you know and so
one way or the other i know i'm going to
figure out how to do it and the hope is
that you can kind of keep building and
get bigger
i think things like commercials and
branded kind of stuff is a really good
way for filmmakers to try to make money
and make a living doing filmmaking
because
there is actual
is an actual business there where you
get paid you know to go and make
something but you're still telling
stories you're still being a filmmaker
um so i think i mean that's the path i
kind of took to be able to kind of
support myself while not having a day
job or whatever
so
that's not easy to get into that either
but i think that's kind of a one way to
go about it
but on the other hand
you know if you also want to be a writer
or something like that maybe you should
take a normal job and then spend your
free time you know or the time you can
take off because of that job to then
just write or to focus on that so i
don't know if there's one perfect way
but it's definitely um
not an easy career and um
i don't think you should go into it
thinking you're going to become rich and
famous but because you want to do this
because it's what you love
it sounds like you have to be prepared
to be very resourceful and just not
needing everything spelled out for you
sounds like you've pieced together a lot
of things on your own
yeah 100 i mean it's just all about
putting together
that puzzle of like you know
what you can
how you can pull something off and then
at the same time how you can kind of
make a living and and that still amounts
for me you know i mean i'm i've just
made a film but i still have to do
commercials too you know i'm trying to
write other stuff so it's i don't think
it ever stops you know uh it's always
just kind of this uh
i don't know what you would call it uh
this dance i guess of trying to figure
that out but um yeah i don't know i i
couldn't do anything else i know that
did you ever have a day job for a short
time
never like a traditional day job like
the closest thing was running this film
festival which was a day job i'd go in
there every day and do it we had an
office for a while i mean like so that
was my day job but it was different
because i had created it it was
something i was super excited about it i
don't think i could be the person who
sits in the office and and works for
someone else that's just not me
especially this point i would figure out
something else i would have to do you
know if that was what i had to go but
um
again that just kind of fits with my
personality which is i don't like to
like be forced to do something i want to
go and go and make something um
so i think i would rather like i don't
know become like um a tour guide in some
other country or like uh
i don't know do something totally random
uh that wasn't being kind of controlled
and forced into a career but uh yeah
magician yeah maybe go back to that
what advice would you give to 17 18 19
year olds on making their first feature
film i think if you were a really young
kind of late teenage early 20s trying to
make a feature film
i think my first advice would be is that
actually the best thing to do um that's
what i did
and it was
the perfect thing i guess for me because
it led me to where i am now but
i just wonder
is it what's really going to help you
the most and so
i think
if you have an incredible feature script
that is super personal and
is something that could be made at a
realistic budget and you feel really
confident then go do that for sure
but
maybe it would be better to
make a short film or a proof of concept
or or kind of develop your skills a
little bit more um
i think i had this idea when i was that
age that i just had to make a feature
film because that's what would
legitimize me or allow me to kind of go
make the next thing and i think that was
partly just because of the era because
short films weren't really available
because this was this was before kind of
online platforms to watch them
everything like that and so to be a
filmmaker was to make a feature film but
i don't think
that's necessarily the case anymore i
think that
um
you can make a short film and and
it can create other opportunities i mean
even in the feature i just made
in order to allow me to make this i made
a short film as a proof of concept you
know and so
uh i
and that was essential i had to do that
i don't think i would have been able to
do it without that and so i think my
advice would just be to
to really make sure if you're gonna put
in all the energy is that is that the
right thing
um the other side of that is i know a
lot of people just make short film after
short film and never
do a feature or never take that next
step so i i also don't think you should
just get stuck because it's also a huge
amount of work to do any kind of film
whether it's a short film or a feature
film it's a huge amount of work so i
think it's just about figuring out what
is going to help you the most excel and
kind of make the next project from there
and if that means making a feature then
go do it but maybe it means also pulling
back a little bit and taking time to
write that really compelling feature
while you make a short or something else
or a documentary
um
i i think that's if i was giving this
advice to myself maybe just to slow down
and pull back even and and and i don't
mean that and lose that excitement and
that energy but just
be a little bit more strategic i guess
about what you're gonna go make
um
i don't know
that's not what i did so i it's hard
it's funny that i'm saying that advice
to people but i did the complete
opposite i just dove in and did it but
i feel like
that's what the more sane advice would
be to kind of take it a little slower
well the environment has changed since
2003 when you i mean your story is very
unique i think it's very interesting but
i mean to have
you know this thing in the back of the
variety or whatever publication that was
to say hey we're looking for this the
whole thing is a very interesting
journey but for today's
temperament and costs and everything but
can people get stuck in this sort of
short film
just making one after another and never
progressing or is that not a bad thing
i mean i think people can definitely get
stuck making short film after short film
i think
if your intent is not to really become a
career filmmaker but just a lot of
people make films short films
and they have regular jobs they have
other things in their life they just
love making films and there's nothing
wrong with that like people should keep
doing that i mean everyone should make a
story if they're compelled to do it
but i think if you really want to be a
director as your career
making a short film after one after the
other forever
is either a sign that if it's not
getting you somewhere else then maybe
there's problems with your your
filmmaking or your your something there
is not working or you need to reshift
your focus you know maybe it's it's
finding a
a story that's even more personal or
compelling or it's finding something
someone else wrote if you're not the
stronger writer or maybe it's making a
documentary i don't know
um
or maybe it's taking that leap to go
then try to do a feature
um it's really hard because it's like
there's not one perfect path you know
and so it's it's hard to say but
i definitely think
you
you want to um kind of have some sort of
momentum going and
and
if
if that's not happening maybe you got to
figure out a way to shift it up